you
- on Putin's walk hello everyone I'm
Masahiro Sakurai the director of the
super smash brothers ultimate game I'm
Sora limited long time no see the hero
from Dragon Quest is joining the battle
and that means I have some new
information to share with you usually we
prepare a script for Nintendo Direct and
we have editors put various cuts
together but this time I'd like to take
more of a live stream approach and
present it myself if you don't have much
of a budget for this while I discuss
I'll be playing with the controller as
well I hope you enjoy it but before we
get into it I should mention that the
Dragon Quest series began in 1986 it's
an iconic Japanese role-playing game it
wouldn't be an exaggeration to say the
Dragon Quest was what popularized RPGs
in Japan and beyond that it's a
top-notch game that's become a cultural
phenomenon the latest entry in the
series is Dragon Quest 11 s echoes of
elusive age definitive edition which is
releasing soon on nintendo switch so
please look forward to it today I'll be
playing the development version of the
ROM so there may be parts where the
camera seems different from the version
you have at home I hope you understand
[Music]
here's the lineup all for heroes I think
to sum this scene alone might seem
pretty astonishing this one is the hero
from Dragon Quest 11s the one that's
releasing soon the 16 year old was
dubbed the darkspawn and he wields a
weapon called the supreme sort of life
now for the hero from Dragon Quest 3
this is the hero urgent and he's 16
years old he's equipped with Eric's
sword actually in 3 and 11 the hero
shield designs are almost identical so
we've changed them up a bit it's all in
the details next the hero from Dragon
Quest 4 chapters of the chosen this 17
year old is the ancestor of the bride
from Dragon Quest 5 hand of the heavenly
bride he's equipped with destiny can
sword
lastly the hero from Dragon Quest a
journey of the cursed King an 18 year
old who isn't affected by the curse
Munchie is in his pocket and as a former
Royal Guardsman
he's equipped with the Dragon King sword
that said it may be a bit tough to
distinguish them using just the name
heroes so if you want to refer to each
of them individually here are their
names
the hero who 11s is 11 the hero from 3
is Utterson the hero from four is solo
and the hero from 8 is 8 you can use
these names to reference them a few
Bibles also they each have a color
variation
the coloring and design of these
variations are based on characters from
the series
can you guess who they are this is
actually the very first time that the
heroes use Dragon Quest series have been
able to fight each other it was allowed
to finally happen in Super Smash
Brothers ultimate and for that I am very
pretty
[Music]
beautiful each hero has a different
voice actor and I'd like to introduce
them now here they are the heroes in
11th is Mizuki Saiga this hero speaks
11s but the action in this game is
different so her voice acting needed a
bit more energy the hero from 3 is
played by Nobuyuki Hiyama you might say
the king of braves is playing the hero
but he voiced linked in the original
Super Smash Brothers and super smash
brothers melee games so you could say he
was already a hero he's definitely a pro
and out of all the voice actors his
recording session went the fastest the
hero from 4 is voiced by Takeshi kuzava
he's a veteran voice actor and asked for
a lot of detail on the backstory of his
character and this has carried over into
his performance
the hero from eight is voiced by Yuki
Kaji it was apparently a dream of his to
do voice works for the Super Smash
Brothers and the Dragon Quest series so
he was happy to have both dreams come
true at once the heroes from 3 4 & 8 are
being voiced for the first time in the
series and calling out the spell names
is also a serious first now let's get a
look at these fighters in actions
the animations are a bit more energetic
than the standard sword users since we
aim to match the style of akira toriyama
sometimes the hero smash a result in a
critical flaw it happens at random but
when it does we'll perform an extra
strong attack these critical hits
actually match the look of critical hits
and various installments of the series
note the subtle nuances the hero is
equipped with a shield which can block
various projectiles his forward Toma is
a shield bash attack that can also be
used to block his neutral special is the
Friz family of spells
Friz frizzle
and for frizz
you can stop your charge in the middle
by shielding and then you can resume
charging the debt then you could store
the full charge until you're ready to
unleash it at any time however even if
you've charged up at the Friz nothing
will happen if you don't have enough MP
at the time so be careful
hero site special produces SAP type
spells enter the command quickly for a
SAP which is a good way to keep
opponents in check
hold it down a little longer for as
Apple which has a pretty good reach and
if you charge it up all the way you let
loose a cos app in each of these spells
and use your sword with lightning to
power up your attacks
next is the whoosh family spells which
can be used for recovery performing a
short up special results in a whoosh
charging it a little bit results in a
swoosh in charging it up all the way
results in accra speech you can only
store a charge with frizz type spells a
whoosh is fairly stunted requiring only
a little MP a swoosh actually provides a
bit more lateral movement a Ksyusha
allows you to recover even if you fall
pretty far also use type spells can blow
enemies into the air
that way you can interfere with the car
it next is heroes down total or man's
election his down special pulls up a
random list of commands doing so allows
you to use a spell or other move boom
simply raises your attack power play
with the fully charged smash attack you
can deal with this much damage now for
psycho it increases the power of your
next attack the difference between this
one and infer is that it can only be
used once but the effect lasts until
your attack finishes even if you miss
next up bounce it reflects your opponent
spells and other projectiles
[Music]
if you both cast balance
The effect of the reflect will be
exponential he'll that you reduce your
damage percentage flame slash can spread
damage the wide area in front of you the
crackle slash can freeze opponents
[Music]
accelerate all significantly increases
your speed
[Music]
KABOOOM sets off a mighty explosive
spell
the snooze puts opponents to sleep that
way you can follow it up with the VP
attack maybe something like hatchet man
and then there's flack this fearsome
spell could potentially ko an opponent
in one hit
however the opponent's damage percentage
will ultimately determine the effect so
if they're damaged percentage is low
it's less likely to activate Zuni this
foul is well suited for recovery as
demonstrated it lets you recover from
anywhere but you may hit your head on
the ceiling to Clank when you cast a
spell you become impervious to attacks
watch out for a metal sludge metal slash
is a skill that can KO a metal opponent
in once it hocus pocus is a spell with
unpredictable effects
Oh looks like it slowed me down but not
all of its effects are bad sometimes
good things happen to
magic fish as you can see my MPA between
in racket because the spell uses all
your remaining MP to deal massive damage
the amount of MP you have will determine
how effective it is
and finally kamikaze this spell produces
an extremely powerful explosion on that
is also results in self-destruction
he has many different special moves in
fact of all the fighters hero has the
highest number of them in the game you
can close the command selection before
choosing a spell by pressing the R
button that way you can try again and
hope for a different set of spells
that's his final smash Giga slash and
it's no mierqis at this move calls upon
all the past protagonists to lend the
hero their power for one mighty blow
this attack has a high vertical range
and if it's within or in-game meters it
will connect commandos and doctor the
command selection move is unlike any
other in the game it may be a bit hard
to imagine how it works
so I'll fight a CPU opponent for a while
I'm fighting the egg drizzles alters I'm
the hero from eight and the CPU is the
hero from for the sage starts off on
this platform which begins to rise
you can use fizz to keep opponents to
check without charge I'll use sample
from a distance
[Music]
the CPUs counter attacks are pretty good
I think attire command selection snooze
[Music]
good stuff kaboom I'm a little low on NP
so I'm going to attack to refill it but
meanwhile the CPU filled up their final
smash meter I'm not going to run use it
Oh critical hit
[Music]
big deal I'll go ahead and use
accelerator
and the final smash hope I can finish a
Monica nice oops
I used hatchet man but ended up blocking
a projectile with it
[Music]
Oh
is he gonna do it ohoo he got me I was
trying to cover tackle his track his
class that's coming down and at the edge
of the screen no less in these
free-for-all battles it's pretty
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this stage is called
aggressive altering and it's based on a
location in Dragon Quest 11s one
difference is that the platform rises
which is very Super Smash Brothers
we're passing closeby cetacean after
that we'll be able to see all of her
drea the giant tree in the background is
an important point in Dragon Quest 11s
you can see a taco walking by
while the taco is out there some sort of
platform will appear we just passed our
boria and you can see what looks like a
rainbow bridge and now we pass havens
above
[Music]
you'll see slimes appear in the back but
sometimes we'll see liquid metal
Steinberg here - those are really rare
[Music]
as we pass cetacean again we draw near
to the giant tree
[Music]
as we make our way up the tree we can
see a light which also appears in Dragon
Quest 11s
and then we finally make our way back
around by the way there's something over
here
sometimes a treasure chest appears on
the stage as you can see here if you
open it you get an item but it could
also be a travesty
[Music]
it's a minute if you try your hardest
you might defeat it you don't have to
fight it but if you manage to beat it
you get an item although Yggdrasil altar
is based on the world of 11s I felt a
bit unfortunate to have only one or two
songs in that game so instead we decided
to compile a collection of field and
battleships for each hero flood is what
it looks like players who have an
emotional attachment to specific music
tracks can use the my music engine to
pick their favorite ones to play well of
course you can also enjoy them by using
the sound test each you won't be able to
select the famous prelude that way at
the end of the prelude we'll play of the
hero's victory scream
we've also added other content including
simple spirit / - please look out for
that as well
[Music]
Tibo will be available on Tuesdays July
30th if you have the fighters pass if
you should be able to get them right
away we're also planning to make them
available individually for $5.99 we're
also adding in new me fighter costumes
please take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
used along with Hiro the version 4.0
update will also be available
[Music]
there will now be a time limit on the
final smash meter
that'll make it harder to use your
attack range to play a waiting game so I
think it's better to just use your final
smash minutes ready it will stick around
for a while and you'll be able to tell
how long do you have by looking at a
mirror which will deplete over time
we're also adding a very easy difficulty
to adventure mode so if a battle is just
too difficult for you to clear or if you
simply want to have a relaxing time
playing please try it out another new
feature will let you try and predict the
winner during spectator mode then you
can exchange the points you accumulate
for an items even if your prediction is
wrong there's nothing to lose so I
suggest supporting fighters to your
heart's content
[Music]
an online tournament will also be added
in to enter an in-game tourney all you
have to do is select the mode the rules
are preset but they'll change
periodically I hope you enter these
tourneys over and over we also plan to
hold a special event Therese from time
to time what's more there are other new
additions like being able to intuit
screenshots into the videos you edit and
being able to consecutively play videos
that have been added to share content
[Music]
there are new amiibo available now
isabell pokemon trainer and Pichu each
one will be available in a yellowish
package so keep an eye
finally the fighter known as hero will
be distributed soon but Dragon Quest 11
as echos and elusive age definitive
edition that were released on September
27 so please check that out as well we
tried a live stream light format this
time but I'm still not sure if we will
do this every time a new fighters
released regardless I hope you have fun
with hero see you next time